We've talked a little bit,
I think in this,
in this series about Pinocchio,
but if we have it doesn't matter.
Um,
you see there's Jimminy cricket at the opening of the Pinocchio movie
pointing to a star,
which is roughly the Nativity Star for all intents and purposes.
And it's um,
it's a symbolic indicator of something diamond light and pure,
right glimmering in the darkness that's transcendent and above the horizon upon
which to fix your eyes.
And so that's the thing is you need that technically.
And the reason you need that is because we know enough about psychology now to
know that almost all of the positive emotion that you're going to experience in
your life and positive emotion is analgesic by the way,
right?
It actually quells pain.
So it's not just positive.
It also gets rid of negative,
which is a big plus.
Almost all the positive emotion that you're going to feel.
You're going to feel in relationship to a goal because you feel positive emotion
as you approach a goal.
And so if you want to feel positive emotion,
then you need a goal.
And then you might think,
well,
if you want to maximize that positive emotion,
which is enthusiasm and also what pulls you out into the world as well as
feeling good,
then you need the best possible goal.
Well that because that's going to engage the largest segments of the year being
like if your goal is too narrow,
then a bunch of you isn't going to be on board for it.
You know?
If the goal is well developed and multifaceted,
then all of you can partake in that.
Even your negative elements,
even your anger and your fear can get on board with that,
let's say so you need a goal,
man,
that's worthy.
You got us.
Thank you.
Good.
You need a goal that justifies the tragedy and malevolence of life.
That seems to be the bottom line.
Now maybe you think,
well,
there's no goal that can do that.
It's like,
well,
there are still better and worse schools,
so and I,
I'm not convinced that there are no goals that can do that.
I think that's an open question.
You'd never know that until you pursued the proper goal long enough to find out
who you would be as a consequence of pursuing it.
That's also your destiny or your existential voyage,
right?
It's also not something that anyone else can do for you.
Someone can say,
get your act together for Christ's sake and get it.
Get good at it.
That's,
that'll make the world unfold best for you.
But there's no way you can know that without doing it.
And unless you think you've done a particularly stellar job of that,
then you have no reason to doubt its potential validity.